ana b 3 e body
[音楽]
高校生の時私は人生に悩んでいました
今となっては何に悩んでいた彼についてはもう忘れてしまっているんですけれども
とにかくあの時私は思い悩んでいました
しかし
ふと
ある日
あれ
例えばもし
明日この地球が
大爆発をしてなくなってしまったとしても
宇宙から見れば全くたいしたことない
うってことない出来事なんじゃないか
そう思いました
そうするとそれまで悩んでいた自分が急にものすごく小さく感じて同時にじゃあ別に
自分が人生をどういうふうに生きるのも自由なんじゃないかそう考えました
そして自分の人生がもし完全に自由だとしたら
自分はどんな人生を生きたいかと考えました
そして私は
それだったら
楽しかったと言って死ねる人生を生きたいと思いました
[拍手]
私は20階まで技術の分野で自分の内面を絵画や立体作品などで表現する作家活動を
行っていました
しかし7年前初めて出産を経験し育児がスタートするとそれまでとは違った視点で自分
の表現を考える必要性に迫られました
経験者の方は
ご存知だと思うんですけれども育児が始まったことで自分が自由に使える時間が
ものすごく減ってしまったということです
限られた時間の中で出来る自分がやりたいことは何かを見つめ直し
私は美術という枠にとどまらず
暮らしを含めた広い範囲での表現を作っていきたいと考えました
私は現在
糸島の竹93年の古民家で
回収作業を行いながらばづくりの活動を行っています
私がこのようにして自分の人生を歩んできた中で悩み事やモヤモヤすること
葛藤は
いつもありました
どうにかしたいと思う時
人生の選択を迫られる時何かしらの一歩を踏み出すとき私が何を基準に選択をしてきた
か
それは先ほどお話しした自分が楽しいと思う人生を生きるぞという部分です
私が自分が楽しいと思う人生を生きるために
指標にしていることが2つあります
一つ目は
安全策をとらない
リスクを恐れないということです
二つ目は
人生面白い方に別途
迷ったときは必ず自分が面白いと感じる方にかけるということです
さてそのような風にして人生を決断していくと
ということになるか
それは淡いによってはなかなか
大変なことになったりもします例えば
私は数年前田舎で場所探しがしたいと思うんですけれどもそれがなかなかうまくいかず
結果的に当時3歳の息子と家出をします
その結果どうなったかというと行く当てのない子連れ旅となり
むちゃくちゃしんどいということになりました
また
その後紆余曲折ありながらもどうにか否かで家が見つかるんですけれどもその見つかっ
た古民家をいい感じに回収したいと思って勢いだけで破壊を行いその結果どうなったか
と言うと今現在この冬家の中が
うちゃくちゃ寒い
ということになったりしていますちょうど寒波が来て家の中での質問ですね
あの一度記録しております
でもそういう大変なことっていうのは一般的にはなるべく
起こらない方がになるべくなら避けたい
ネガティブなことのようだに思っていますでも私はその大変なことを比較的
歓迎しています
なぜなら
大変なことが起こっているときというのはどうにか
状況打開しないといけないというときでじゃあどうすると考えるシーンです
私はそのじゃあどうすると考えることがとてもクリエイティブだなぁと感じてワクワク
してきます
またその大変な状況というのも中に入ってしまわずに少し距離をとって客観的に見る
ことができれば大抵なんだか面白かったり人生の話のネタになったり
経験としての肥やしになったり人間としての厚みになると考えています
そしてその大変な状況を押すチャーどうするという課題に関してはより面白く
合理的で美しいと思える解決方法にたどり着くまで試行錯誤を続けます私はその試行
錯誤も大好きです
そして自分が素晴らしいと思える方法が見つかった時がまた最高の気分です
私は大変なことをまあ比較的ちょっと歓迎しているのでもしかしたら壁にぶつかったり
転んだりすることが多いのかもしれません
でもこの通り私にとってはぶつかったり転んだりすることはむしろこれは人生をより
面白く楽しくするチャンスなんだというふうに思い
ているところもあります
そういった理由で一般的には良くないと言われるような出来事であっても私は
前向きにとらえることができていると考えています
私が自分の選択と
起こる出来事を楽しんでいくために大切にしていることが3つあります
1つ目は自分の決断を信じるということ
二つ目は必ず明るい未来があるんだという確信を持つこと
3つ目は自分が望む方向に行くんだという意志を持つことです
もちろんでも落ち込んだり悲しい気持ちになったりボロボロの気分になることはあり
ます
でも
まあ自分が自分らしく生きていると思えるのであれば
まされて落ち込んでもまぁいいかと
思っています
そして
一つ大事なところなんですけれどもやって大変なことになったりもうロボになったりし
ていると必ずその時その時で助けてくれる人が現れます
助けてくれる人のおかげです
4都市は追い詰められたりボロボロになったりすることがあってもどうにか自分の心
まではおらずにここまでたどり着くことができています
本当にありがたく思っています
なんだったら
大変なことになったりボロボロになっていていいしてる私を見て面白がって
愛ある感じで笑っていただけると私はうれしいです
私が私だしく人生を楽しんでいて人もそれを見て楽しんでいただけるんであれは私は
最高にハッピーです
その時その時の自分自身に対して自分らしくあるための選択をしていくこと
それは自分がウキウキしたりワクワクしたりする方を選ぶということです
逆に言うと自分が窮屈だなぁと感じる方は選ばないということです
私の選択は人から見れば
窮屈そうだなとかなんでそんなことしてんだろうっていう風に見えるかもしれません
でも私が自分らしくあるために選んだ道ならそれは自由で喜びにあふれています
人はもしかしたら失敗だとかそんなことをやらない方がいいとか不幸な出来事だとか
いうかもしれません
でも
自分が
今の状態に対して
ok だと
思えるかどうかが自分の人生では一番大切なことです
私が私らしくあるということ
あなたがあなたらしくあるということ
そのことを大切にすれば自分も周囲もそれぞれが豊かに生きていけると私は考えてい
ます
ありがとうございました
[拍手]